ضمن سلسله من الدعوات الغربيه لدفع
اوكرانيا للتفاوض مع روسيا ذكرت صحيفه وسط
جورنال الامريكيه ان كبار المسؤولين
الامريكيين بداوا في دفع اوكرانيا للتفكير
في عقد محادثاته سلام مع روسيا تحسبا
لتعثر التقدم ميدانيا بسبب دخول فصل
الشتاء واشارت صحيفه الى ان توقعات بانه
اوكرانيا لن تحقق مكاسبك كبيره في ساحه
المعركه خلال الاسابيع المقبله دفعت
واشنطن وبعض المسؤولين الاوروبيين الى
تساؤل عن موعد ظهور ضغوط العلنيه للمطالبه
بالتواصل الى التسويع ولفت الصحيفه الى ان
الولايات المتحده وبعض حلفائها يشعرون
بالقلق من
استنزافي مخزونته من الاسلحه بمعدل لا
يمكن تحمله
بين كواليس الحرب الاوكرانيه الدائره
يتردد حديث في الدبلوماسيه والمفاوضات
الولايات المتحده الدعم الكبير ورئيسها
يبدو ان مسؤوليها بداوا دفع فريق الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه للتفكير بعقد محادثات سلام مع
موسكو تحسبا لتعثر التقدم الميداني وفقدان
الزخم المتحقق حاليا على الارض مع حلول
فصل الشتاء كبار المسؤولين الامريكيين
بداوا يتساءلون بشكل علنيا عن حجم الاراضي
التي يمكن كسبها وباي تكلفه وفقه ما نقلت
صحيفه
يجب ان يكون هناك اقرار متبادل بان النصر
قد يتعذر تحقيقه من خلال الوسائل العسكريه
لذلك نحتاجه الى اللجوء الى وسائل اخرى
ووفقا لصحيفه الامريكيه فان الحديثه في
واشنطن عن تحولات محتمله في الحرب بدا مع
اقتراب فصل الشتاء وزياده المخاوف من
ارتفاع معدلات التضخم الناتج عن ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه والغذاء الى جانب سقوط عشرات
الالاف من الضحايا من الجانبين فضلا عن
مليارات الدولارات من المساعدات الامريكيه
التي تم ضخها الى كياف حيث لا فتاه
الصحيفه الى ان الولايات المتحده وبعض
خلفائها يشعرون بالقلق من استنزاف
مخزوناتهم من الاسلحه بمعدل لا يمكن تحمله
مضيفه ان الدعم العسكريه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا هذا العام والذي بات يقترب من
19 مليار دولار يفوق المساعدات الاوروبيه
بكثير
وبحسب ما نقالته عن اشخاص المطالعين على
المناقشات فان نواصم اوضحت لاوكرانيا انك
تحتاج على الاقل لان تبدو منفتحه على حل
مضيء وهي الرساله التي نقلها مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جاك سوليفان الى الرئيس
الاوكراني خلال زيارته الاخيره لكياف ملوك
الشيخ العربيه
نناقش هذه التطورات مع ضيوفنا من موسكو
تيمور دويدار الخبير في قطاع الاعمال
والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك ومن واشنطن
الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات
حسين عبد حسين اهلا بكم ضيفه الكريمين
واسمح لي ان ابدا من واشنطن معك يا دكتور
حسين دكتور حسين في الواقعه عن ورسي جورنا
التي نقلت هي نفسها عن مصادر مطلعه كما
وصفتها مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جاك
سوليفان طلب من الرئيس همم زينسكي ان يقدم
او يطرح همم مطالب واقعيه كما نقلت
الصحيفه اكثر من ذلك تحدث عن ضروره انفتاح
على مفاوضات مع روسيا هل تقرا تغيرا طفيفا
في الموقف الامريكي تجاه الازمه
مساء الخير ستريم هذه الطبيعه السياسات
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه حتى الحروب
التي تنخرط فيها امريكا بشكل مباشر ان في
فيتنام او في العراق او في افغانستان او
اي حرب اخرى غالبا ما تنخرط الولايات
المتحده مع تفكير بافق التوصل الى تسويه
او انشراج الولايات المتحده
تكره الحروب المفتوحه الامد ذات التكاليف
يعني المفتوحه كذلك ولذلك يبدو ان بعض
المسؤولين في واشنطن يعتقدون الفرصه ذهبيه
لانه ما حلول هذا الفصل قد يتراجع القتال
اوكرانيا حققت انتصارات يمكن بها ان تحفظ
الوجه
كان من اهداف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لاضعاف روسيا اكثر واكثر
لا اعتقد ان الهدف الرئيسي كان اضعف روسيا
الهدف الرئيسي كان الحفاظ على النظام
بالعالم ومن روسيا من يعني قدم اجزاء من
اوكرانيا غير القرن طبعا شبه جزيره القرم
موضوع اخر ولكن كان الهدف هو عدم السماح
لاي دوله قدم من حدود دوله اخرى اعتقد انه
هذا الهدف تحقق ولذلك ترى الولايات
المتحده الان الاوضاع يعني هي في مصلحه
اوكرانيا الى حد ما تناسب همم تقديم حلول
ويعني الذهاب الى الدبلوماسيه
هل هو المسار الطبيعي كما قال ضيفه وهي
استراتيجيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
فتح الافاق للمفاوضات او ترى حضرتك بانه
الوقت مناسب لمحاوله ايجاد حلول يفرزها
همم تفرضها المرحله الشتاء قادمه هناك
مشاكل وصعوبات كذلك تعيش الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو اوروبا كما يقول بعضهم
يا رب والولايات المتحده في شجار الان
ربما لا نراه لكن الدخان صاعد
بمشكله هذه الحرب
وخضوع السياسيين الاوروبيين لمشيئه واشنطن
هذه مشكلتهم هم الذين حرضوا موسكو على
اتخاذ تركي الخطوه بالعمليه العسكريه
ومن سياسه الولايات المتحده شيء غريب فعلا
انهم يتطرقون الى محادثات فمن واضح ان هم
يحسون بخساره شنيعه تكبدتها الكتله
الغربيه بقياده واشنطن
فام لا ادري ضايفك تحدث عن انتصارات
وكرانيه لا ادري اين صراحه لان صراحه في
سبتمبر روسيا حققت اهدافها
وسيطر على الجزء همم
الشرقي من مساحات من نهر
مستقبلا قد يكون همم والشتاء في صالح
روسيا عندما يتجمد الوحل ممكن ان يتم
السيطره على اوكرانيا انت طلب ذلك الامر
لان هناك صراحه يعني انا لا ادري درست
عسكريه لكن لدي زملاء مثل باحثين ههه في
هذا الشان لا ادري لماذا تم الانسحاب من
مدينه خيرسون عاصمه همم
هذه ارض مسطحه وكان ممكن صد اي هجوم لاي
قوات مهما كان عددتها
اجل المفاوضات سيد تيمور البعث ذلك يطرح
من قبل حتى بدايه هذه العمليه العسكريه
ونحن تحدثنا عن ذلك فالطلب الوحيد من
واشنطن والاوروبيين همم اعاده هيكله
المنظومه الامنيه في القاره الاوروبيه حتى
الان لن
يعني ينصدون فعلى الكلام ده همم يعني ونحن
ندفع الان ذلك ضد هذه الحرب لكن الان
الطلبات لانهاء المسيره ان كانت في
اوكرانيا او خارجه اوكرانيا طيب حضرتك ترى
بان الغرب بيعيش همم اقسى همم ظروف
همم سيد حسين هو ضايفي يا طرح سؤال يقول
لك همم كيف يمكن ان تنظر بان الغرب همم
نجح همم في هذه المرحله هو يرى فشلا
يتكبده الغرب يرى خسائر تتكبدها الجهه
الغربيه
قال ان هي الانتصارات ثم قال انه هو لا
يعرف لماذا انسحبت روسيا من خيرسون وعليه
ان يسال زملاء العسكريين اقترح انه يسال
زملاء العسكريين لانه الانسحاب يبدوا له
هزيمه انا لست عسكريه ولكن لماذا تنسحب
قوه تنتصر يعني التي تنصح بها القوه التي
تهزم هناك مساحات كبيره استعادتها القوات
الاوكرانيه واضحه يعني هذه لا انا عسكري
ولا هو عسكري ثم انه كل العمليه الروسيه
التي كانت على مشارف كيا باليوم صارت في
في مكان اخر وروسيا غيرت من الاهداف كذا
مره يعني هي بدات تريد خلى اليوم صارت
تتحدث عن اراضي حتى اراضي اعلن الضمها
واعلنت انها روسيه ثم تراجع عنها لو اخذنا
النقاط فقط التي بدات فيها روسيا الحرب في
فبراير الماضي والنقاط التي تتحدث عنها
روسيا اليوم لان هناك تراجع وهذا التراجع
وهذا الفرق هو الذي يدفع الولايات المتحده
الى الاعتقاد انه يعني ليس من المفروض همم
ايقاع الذل بروسيا اساسا المفروض يعني
انتصار ساحق ما حكم الاوكرانيا الوضع
الحالي ممكن ان يعني يتم التوصل له نهايه
صراعيه في مصلحه الطرفين يعني هناك خسائر
كبيره لدى الروس هناك خسائر اكبر لدى
الاخرى ولذلك اعتقد الولايات المتحده ترى
ان الوقت صار مناسبا بعد ما تعب
المتقاتلون وصار وقت الحوار والسلام عليكم
بانه موضوع خرسون وتراجع القوات الروسيه
من خرسون الموضوع غير مفهوم لدى جهات
عديده في الواقع كيف تتراجع القوات
الروسيه من منطقه المسطحه كما يقول
للسيتيمور وساهل حتى اجراء المعارك فيها
بحسب قوله هو السنادا على بعض القراءات
العسكريه هل تعتقد بانه هذه الخطوه هي
خطوه همم حسن
نيه روسيه على الاقل
بناء مفاوضات مع الجانب همم مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اوروبا
قد تكون كذلك ولكن يعني روسيا استنفذت
القدره على تغيير موازين الحرب ومضت
تستهدف البنيه التحتيه ومحطات انتاج
الطاقه والكهرباء
انه من هنا وصاعدا ستكون حرب فقط هي عباره
ولذلك ترى الولايات المتحده انه الوقت
مناسب لان هناك تعب لدى الجهه طبعا السيد
زيلانكي لم يتوقف طالما هو يتمتع بدعم
وطالما هو يحقق يعني دفاعه ولذلك المتحده
انه قامت ب يعني اقناع انه نحن ندعمك
للدفاع ولكن نحن لا ندعمك الهجوم او يعني
اقتحام روسيا هناك محاوله فرط توازن من
جهتين اولا الدفاع ولكن في نفس الوقت يعني
عدم الاندفاع الى حد ما الذي تريده
الولايات المتحده
لم تاتي فقط من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اتت كذلك سيد تيمور من همم حر
شمال الاطلسي من الناتو الامين العام لحلف
شمال الاطلس السلطان بارك همم قال كذلك
بان الامر ما يترك ليكرانيا لتقرير الشروط
المقبوله اود التوقف عند مصطلح الشروط
المقبوله للمفاوضات لانهاء الحرب شروط
المقبوله في عين من الشروط المقبوله
بالنسبه لروسيا شروط المقبوله بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا هل ترى تغير كذلك في موقف
الاوروبيين اتجاه هذه الازمه
لا احد يعتبر اوكرانيا هنا في هذه
المعادله ليس لها لا دور ولا اي شيء من
حيث البدايه
ما همم الان البافرزون موجوده على خط شرق
نهر النيبر
والقوات الروسيه مستعده الاسراء على
اوكرانيا عموما لكن همم يعني ما هو الداعي
بصراحه يعني هذا هنا مفترق الطرق
لان هناك فعلا داعي للسلاح على اوكرانيا
بالكامل كامله
توافق سياسي وقرار سياسي بين موسكو واشنطن
في وقفه العمليات العسكريه
الوضع على ما هو عليه
هذه الاربعه محافظات
منظمه الى روسيا ونوعا ما انتهى الامر لكن
انا اقول ان الامر لن ينتهي ان انتهى
لسانه او سنتين ربما او حتى لعقد من الزمن
لكن همم
هذا ان لم يتم الاستلام على اوكرانيا
كامله او تغيير نظام الحكم ويكون موالي
موسكو همم لن تدوم اي عمليه السلام اكثر
من عده سنوات
الذي يمكن ان اتحدث عنه لبناء هذه
المفاوضات هو همم اربعه مقاطعات همم تمكنت
روسيا مينا سيطره عليها وتعتقد سي تيمور
بانه واشنطن قادره ان تقبل بهذا المفاوضات
اذا ما تحدثنا عن ثنائيه
التي تقول بانها هي المسيطره في النهايه
على هذه المفاوضات وليس طرف ثالث تعتقد
بانها واشنطن ستقبل
نعم انا اعتقد انه واشنطن قبلت يعني من
حيث المبدا يعني هل لا ارى لا اعتقد ان
واشنطن ضد دار من نخب من العرب المتحدثين
على القنوات الاعلاميه فا هناك بالطبع
قبول من حيث البدايه احنا بدات العمليه
العسكريه كل ما هوا روسي
وبالطبع لن لا يريد احد الموت لا في الغرب
في الدول الغربيه وما عدا بولندا العبيطه
والولايات المتحده بالتحديد في صالح
اوكرانيا همم الذين هم روس ايضا همم
الموضوع ليس همم هو ليس بازمه همم هو همم
يعني همم
رايك هل واشنطن يوم كان ان تقبل بهذه
الصوره بان تضم روسيا همم المناطق التي
سيطرت عليها او المقاطعات التي سيطرت
عليها ومن بعد يبدا التفاوض هذا في سؤال
اول وتعليقك كذلك على ما قاله السيد تيمور
بخصوص ان هذه المفاوضات تسيطر عليها جهتين
وعشان وموسكو ولا دخل لاي جهه اخرى فيها
وهذا يضعنا في اطار الصوره الاولى التي
كنا نتحدث عنها منذ بدايه هذه الازمه بان
اوكرانيا بيدق تحكمت فيه واشنطن لدفعها لي
ازمه ومن ثم لما حان الوقت هي تطلب منها
الخروج همم طبقا لضروريات تحطمها هذه
المرحله
اوكرانيا هي التي تقاتل يعني وهي التي
تخسر من ابنائها هي التي تدفع ثمن البنيه
التحتيه ولا تخدم الولايات المتحده هي
التي ستقاتل عن الاوكران طبعا الدعم يعني
الدعم عسكري ولكن في نهايه المطاف الكلمه
الاوكرانيه ثم ان هذه يعني انا لا اعتقد
انه هذه الجزء الشرقي ان تمت مفاضله طبعا
نحن نتحدث عن امرين اول امر هو وقف الحرب
بين الطرفين بعد وقف
الحربات المفاوضات قد تنجح ولا ولا وقد لا
تنجح ولكن المفاوضات ترتبط بالعقبات فانت
لما التوصل الاتفاقيه سلام شامله وسحبت
روسيا من الاراضي الاوكرانيات طبعا انا
هنا لا اتحدث عن قرب
الموضوع اخر ولكن كل الاراضي التي دخلت
استولت عليها روسيا بعد بدء الحرب فبراير
ان انسحبت منها روسيا يعني نحن نتحدث عن
العوده الى ما قبل الاجتياح الروسي
لاوكرانيا في فبراير الماضي ان عاده
الامور الى ما كانت عليه تقوم الولايات
المتحده اوروبا برفع وقد يتم يعني همم
استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع روسيا
النقطه هنا هنا هي العوده الى مقابل
فبراير همم الماضي ولا اعتقد انه يعني
هناك اهداف ابعد من ذلك اكرانيا طبعا هي
التي تقاتل ان ان رفضت روسيا همم الانسحاب
من هذه المحافظات هناك طب روسيا هي تحت
الحصان
تفضل سيتمور تعليقات
بدات هذه الحرب ريم نحن تحدثنا
الاوروبيين سوف
يصوتون همم
بالاغاثه في الشتاء او على وشك الشتاء
وهناك طلب روسي
الاطلسي الى ما قبل 1991 يعني بولندا دول
البلطيق هنجاريا كل هذه الدول تطلع من حلف
الاطلسي الموضوع معلق حتى الان وهذه
الطلبات لم تن بعد ان ما يزجه باوكرانيا
وجورجيا في همم حضن اليورو الاطلسي انا
اتمنى يعني ان بعد هذه الاشكاليات جميعا
ربما يفنى اليورو الاطلسيه في خلال
السنتين القادمهتين اه النظرنا
للاقتصاديات
وتلك التغييرات في التجاره الدوليه وما
نتج عن هذه المناوشه حتى الان وفي الكل
بالطبع من ان اللاعب قبات اثرت في روسيا
ولا في الاقتصاد الروسي همم وفي حين
قيامها همم ضد الغرب كله اهو حوالي 55
لم تستخدم اه اكثر من 15% من قدراتها
العسكريه في الافراد
وربما لا شيء في العتاد من هو موجود همم
حتى الع ان لاحظتهم هو ليس بالجديد او
حديث ليست بمميت او قاتل همم مثل ما يمكن
ما ان يستخدم من المواد الحارقه والباكم
في نفس الوقت يعني هي تستخدم موضوعيا تلك
الصواريخ
طوسوها نحن تحدثنا عن ذلك عندما سالتيني
مره من المرات عن النووي قلت لك بدل
النووي يوجد مليون شيء يعني غير نوعه
سعيد حسين
الجانب الامريكي همم يرى ما يراه ضيفي
ويقول بان الوضع قادر ان يكون اسود فحانه
همم المجال للتفاوض هل توافق مثل هكذا راي
او قراءه
لا اوافق ابدا لانه يعني اي شخص حتى غير
خبير اي شخص عادي يمكن ان يتابع الاخبار
ويرى انه روسيا استنفذت كل العيدات صارت
تستورد اسلحه ايرانيه
واستنفذت كل المقاتلين الروس يعني يحاولون
العرب من روسيا حتى لا ينخرطون في القتال
في اوكرانيا يعني لا اعرف اين هي لا حرب
واين هي المناوشه هناك
مئات الدبابات الروسيه مئات الطائرات
المقاتلات الروسيه مئات القتلى يعني نحن
نتحدث على كوكبين يعني كانه انا اخترع هذه
التقارير من راسي
الاستاذ
طيب
الكذب هذا الكذب
هو يقول وفي كوكب اخر ويتحدث عن مئات كم
اي يعني
قناه فضائيه
وكحه حضرتك كذلك ونحن يسعدنا حضوركم معنا
دائما للوقوف على هذه التطورات وحتى
للوقوف على وجهات نظر مختلفه هذا يفيد
النقاش ساكتفي معكم بهذا القدر لضيق الوقت
على فكره ليس لشيء اخر لانه الاسئله لا
زالت والنقاش يمكن ان يحتد ولكن لضيق
الوقت اكتفي معكم على ان اعود ل نقاش اخر
ولكن في حلقات اخرى من موسكو تيمور دوار
الخبير في قطع الاعمال والعلاقات الدوليه
ومن واعشقنا البحث المؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه تحسين عبد الحسين شكرا لكم